Hey everybody, it's Mike and uh welcome
to today's presentation on the Order
Flows Delta Scalper. Uh let me just get
my screen up here. Just bear with me.
Screen, make sure I got the right
screen.
Okay, so you know, today what I'll be
talking about is the Delta Scalper from
Order Flows. You know, and one of the
reasons why I chose to do today's
presentation on the Delta Scalper is
because you know, it's a it's a great
tool for analyzing what's happening in
the Order Flow and
you know, while some people have heard
of the Delta Scalper from other vendors,
I was the one that created it first. You
know, people have tried to reverse
engineer. Everyone's always trying to
reverse engineer what I've created. Um
you know, why not get it originally
here, you know, what it's for, how to
use it directly from the source.
Now,
before I begin, you know, just a brief
disclaimer, you know, you understand
that uh you know, trading involves risk
and you know, you shouldn't be trading
with money you can't afford to lose.
All right, so what I'll be talking about
today. Now, if you
just a few ground rules. Um
I don't say ground rules, but you know,
just bear in mind, you know, this is the
agenda that I have scheduled for today.
I'm going to talk about what is Order
Flow Delta, how is Order Flow Delta
calculated, how to use Order Flow Delta,
um talk about trading decisions that are
based on Order Flow Delta. Then I want
to get into the actual Order Flows Delta
Scalper. Talk about um
the different settings. I'm going to
talk about the settings for individual
markets. And then at the end, there will
be a question and answer. Now, if you
have a question, just put it in the chat
or the uh question box. Now, I'm not
going to be monitoring it uh full-time
during the presentation. I'll I'll go
through the questions at the end. Yeah,
I just find that when I stop to take a
look at a question,
um
I I just lose my train of thought, you
know, then, you know, a 45-minute or
1-hour session
turns out to be a 2- or 3-hour session.
So, I just find it a little bit easier
to to
let you know that, you know, if you have
any questions, put it in the chat, put
it in the question box, and
at the end, after I go through the whole
presentation, we'll talk about it, um
your questions. Now,
today's presentation again, you know, is
on the Delta Scalper, okay? So, yeah, I
I do want you to understand that, you
know, I know
when I do presentations on certain
indicators, things like that, people
say, "Well, you know, I had to sit
through this whole thing to watch you
present an indicator." Yeah, that's the
whole point of this, you know, there's a
lot of users, a lot of traders that have
the Delta Scalper, and you know, they
said, "Mike, you know, you should do
some extra training." This is what the
training is. You know, there's people
that sitting on the fence, you know, do
I really need to add this to my trading
arsenal or not? You know, hopefully
today your questions will be answered,
and you can see,
um the indicator, and, you know, if it's
something that you need for trading.
Now,
to see order flow delta, right, you need
to use
an order flow chart, basically. You
can't use, you know, a normal bar chart
and expect to see market generated
information from the order flow on a
normal bar chart because it's not going
to appear there, right? But at the end,
you know, when I talk about the Delta
Scalper, I'm going to show you how we've
taken the information from an order flow
chart,
the delta specifically, and we've put it
into a format that can be analyzed and
read on a normal bar chart.
So, what is order flow delta? Now,
every bar has a delta, okay? And
if you're familiar with an order flow
chart, right, well, the footprint chart,
and you see a lot of numbers, right? You
see numbers on the bid side, you see
numbers on the offer side.
Basically, all you do is you subtract
the number that's traded on the bid from
the number traded on the offer, and
that's going to be your delta.
So, when I say every bar has a delta,
right? Because
what you do is you take uh for example,
this little bar here, okay? You see 4 54
126 6, you add all that up, the total
you get you subtract it from the 11 79
41 and 0. What you're left with is minus
59. So, what that's telling you is there
was 59 more contracts traded on the bid
than traded on the offer.
And people say, "Well,
if there's more traded on the bid than
on the offer, why is it negative?" It's
because what delta measures is the
aggressive trading. What you have is 59
more aggressive sellers, right? The 59
is right here.
59 more aggressive sellers than
aggressive buyers.
Okay? That that doesn't mean that there
wasn't a lot on the offer up here. What
it's telling you, what the delta that
tells you is
there was more aggressive sellers in
this bar than aggressive buyers.
Okay? Then, you know, for example, this
green bar right here in the middle,
right? It's got a delta of positive 16.
So, you add up everything that's traded
on the bid side, everything that's
traded on the offer side, there was 16
more contracts traded on the offer side
than the bid side.
Okay? What's that telling you is
there was more aggressive buying going
on in this bar than aggressive selling.
Now, that doesn't mean there was no
aggressive selling, there was, it just
wasn't enough to turn the delta um
negative, right? The aggressive buyers
were just slightly more in control than
the aggressive sellers.
So, basically, like I said, you know,
every bar has a delta, okay? And
delta is a market generated piece of
information, right? Delta can be
positive, negative, or it can be zero,
right? You see here positive deltas, you
see negative deltas.
Now, there's another subset of delta.
There's max delta and min delta as well
as cumulative delta.
Cumulative delta is the running delta
total for the day. It's like think of it
like volume, right? The the day's
volume. So, up to this point here where
you have this
green uh sorry, this yeah, this this
green candle right here at uh 7:46,
it's cumulative delta's positive 1349.
So, at this point in time, since the
market reopened at 6:00 p.m. or sorry,
5:00 p.m., um
it's built up a positive delta of 1349.
Now, the cumulative delta will rise, it
will fall during the trading day. It it
could be positive, it could be negative.
Max delta is
how strong the positive delta was in a
bar.
Okay, so in again, in this green candle
right here,
you can see max delta of 230. Tells you
in this bar
delta was positive
at a number of 230, right? Period. It
it's it's not taking anything to account
with the um aggressive side. It's
telling you in this bar
the strongest aggressive buying was was
230 contracts positive. And min delta is
the opposite. Okay, so you see minus six
in the same bar. So, it's telling you
the most negative selling was in this
bar was minus six, or six contracts,
okay? So, it's telling you over the
course of the bar, most of the trading
that was happening was on the offer
side, meaning aggressive buyers trading
in the market. Now, people ask, "Well,
what's the difference, you know, what's
an aggressive buyer?" Well, there's
different types of buyers and sellers in
the market.
You have aggressive buyers, aggressive
sellers.
You have passive buyers, passive
sellers. When somebody lifts the offer,
buys at the market,
that's an aggressive buyer. If someone
sells at the market or sells into the
bid, that's an aggressive seller, okay?
Now, aggressive sellers sell to passive
buyers. They're people that working a
bid, right? They're waiting for the
market to come to them. Aggressive
traders don't wait for the market to
come to them. They go to the market.
Now, a passive seller would be somebody
that sits on the offer waiting for
someone to come up and and buy it,
right? Think of it like uh you know,
eBay, right? You we're all familiar with
eBay.
And
you know, you have things that are
auctions,
okay? And then you have things that are
just uh basically selling in a store at
a fixed price. If something is selling
at a fixed price,
that seller is a passive seller. They're
happy to sell, you know, wait for the
buyer to come up and pay their price.
You know, say they have a you know, a
special
pen or something.
And you know, they think it's a
collectible pen. They know that
they they want to sell it for $500. So,
they just put it in their store at $500
and they they wait for the aggressive
buyer to come up and pay that price.
That collector that really wants that
pen is going to be aggressive and pay
that price.
Now, if you have an auction,
right? What you having is you have more
aggressive buying going on. That's a
case of aggressive buying. You don't
necessarily see aggressive selling going
on in an auction. And you know, you have
people competing with each other trying
to you know, lift the offer, pay the
best price possible in the market in
order to secure
um you know, what they're trying to buy.
Now again, you know, every bar has a
delta,
but not every delta is going to matter.
And sometimes delta by itself
has no importance, right?
When you see, "Oh, you know, I got this
bar here. It's got a delta of you know,
this bar over here it's got a delta of
seven." Well, okay. What does that mean?
You know, seven by itself means nothing.
You got to put it in context with what's
happening in the market.
And
once you start understanding, you know,
what the delta means, how to put it
together, string it together with other
bars deltas, and market structure, you
know, the market is going to make a lot
more sense to you because, like I said,
if delta shows who's in control of the
market,
then
you're going to have a good idea of
who's in control of the market, right?
Because imagine imagine, right? You have
a tool that says, "Well, I know
aggressive sellers are are active and
dominating this market because I see a
lot of negative deltas." Then it's then
it's easy. But then once you start
seeing changes in the delta, and I want
to get to this a little bit later, it's
going to tell you when market is getting
weaker or when a market is getting
stronger, when there's signs of
absorption, and
many more ways of analyzing the market.
So again, you know, just to recap, you
know, delta could be positive, it could
be negative, it could be zero.
Sometimes, you know, it's just
coincidence it lands on zero.
I haven't found any
statistical
um
edge when a delta lands on zero
than when it lands on a positive or
negative number, right? It's just more
of a coincidence. Now, remember, right?
Most people use a bar chart
sorry, a time-based chart, like a
1-minute chart.
And after 1 minute, the bar closes and
you start a new bar. And wherever the
delta is at that moment the bar closes
is is what prints. So, you know,
sometimes if you had an extra 1 second,
you know, the delta could have been
positive five or positive 20, you know,
or negative six or something like that.
It it
when it lands on zero, it's more of
coincidence than anything else. Now,
like I said, you know, every bar has a
delta.
Not every delta you see matters. And
especially sometimes
there's deltas that are
kind of neutral in the market, right? So
for example, right? If you're looking at
a market like E-mini S&P's that trade,
you know, thousands of contracts in a
minute, and you have a delta that's like
20,
there's no
nobody really in control.
In many cases, when I see a very small
delta like that, you know, depending on
where the bar is coming in market
structure, you know, I I would treat it
as a sort of neutral, right? Because
nobody's really in control right now.
And and you see that sometimes on a
market that's going sideways, you see
small deltas.
Okay? So,
again, you know, how is order flow delta
calculated? Well, it's calculated by
taking the volume traded on the bid and
subtracting it from the volume that's
traded on the offer. Now,
most footprint charts,
you can actually have the volumes that
traded on the offer and volumes traded
on the bid, if you want to have them on
your screen.
So, for example, right? Right here in
the middle, this middle bar,
you see
delta is 16, right? The third number.
Well, why How is it 16? It's because
when you add everything up traded on the
offer, it's 91 contract, right? The
volume traded on the ask, the volume
traded on the bid is 75. So, that's how
you end up with 16. Just like this red
bar,
volume traded on the ask is 189, volume
traded on the bid is 295. So, that's
minus 106 is the delta.
Okay? So, it's it's it there's no fancy
mathematical equation, you know,
advanced calculus and that you got to
understand. It's it's simple arithmetic,
right? Traders
like to over complicate things
sometimes. You don't need to make it
complicated, right? All you got to do is
is you look at the numbers, right?
Imagine if you run a
you know, just a regular brick and
mortar store,
okay?
And, you know, you you're trying to keep
track of sales.
All right?
You know, it's accounting. Well, how
many coats did I sell this week? Okay?
How many
um you know,
at what price, right? So, you're going
to add it up, you know, okay, I I I sold
20 coats you know, on Monday, 15 coats
on Tuesday.
You know, you you don't necessarily need
to
delve into, you know, all these weird
mathematical formulas. And you know,
that's what traders do, right? If if you
open up
you know, Ninja Trader
I'm going to get into some charts later.
But, you know, if you you open up the
indicators under under Ninja Trader
you know, you got a whole slew of
different indicators that you can use.
All right? You can see in here, right?
You see ADX, you know, Bollinger Bands,
which I don't mind. Um
pivots, candlestick patterns, um
oscillators, volatility, choppiness
index, you know, a lot of these things I
I've no idea what CMO is, you know,
maybe you know, somebody can inform me,
you know, DMI, you know, what that is.
Donchian Channels, double stochastics.
You know, a lot of people they don't
understand really what goes into these
tools that they're just throwing up on
their chart. But, with something like
Delta, right? It it's derived directly
from the order flow. It's derived from
what actually traded in the market. It's
not um
coming in from, you know,
some
massaging of price, right? Taking price
and sort of running it through a
mathematical equation and, you know,
coming up with an answer like that. What
you're seeing in Delta is actually based
on what traded in the market right now,
right? It I always say, you know, order
flow gets you as close to the market as
possible. Well, the reason you know,
what that really means is
you you're basing your trading decisions
on what's happened right now, right?
You're not taking an average from, you
know, the last 50 bars and and running
it through the computer and coming out
with a
a one one number and then you're you're
basing your decision off that, right?
No, you're basing your decision off of
what is actually trading right now.
So, how do you use order flow delta?
Well, like I said,
you're going to use it in several ways,
right? Now, these are not all the ways,
but these are the most common ways.
It's going to help you determine who is
in control of the market, right? Like I
said, generally markets go up on
positive delta, markets go down on
negative delta. Now, there's going to be
instances where a market is going up and
you have negative delta. And you're
going to scratch your head and say,
"Well, Mike said that, you know, delta
shows who's in control of the market.
Why is the market going up
but there's more aggressive selling?"
Well,
the the reason for that is is a simple
one. There's absorption in the market,
okay? That's the second part. Determine
if there's absorption in the market,
right? Imagine a market is is going
higher, but there's still aggressive
selling, that means there's a big buyer
in the market, right? He's Everyone is
selling the heck out of the market, but
he's going to say, "Sure, I'll I'll buy
everything you have. Well, you know,
sell sell me some more, right?" And then
the market still ticks higher, ticks
higher, ticks higher.
Delta's going to help you determine if a
move is showing strength,
right? And
why that's important is because
you know, everyone always says, "Follow
the trend. The trend is your friend."
Oh, that's that's such, you know, a
beautiful statement, but
okay, what you want to do is you want to
be identified to the trend as soon as it
happens, right? You don't want to be
getting on trend,
you know,
three-quarters of the way through, you
know, if there's signs in the market
that, you know what, aggressive buyers
are coming in, stepping up to the plate,
they're starting to, you know,
accumulate a position,
but the market's not moving much. Often
times that shows up in the delta.
Actually, I have an indicator for free
on my website. Um if you go to
orderflows.com, it's called the delta
surge. That you can download it for
free.
Um you just got to enter your email. But
that shows you um
where delta is
you know, slowly building, right? It's a
sign of accumulation and you know, right
before a market starts to take off often
times.
But delta can also use for the opposite,
right? Determine if a move is weakening.
You know, imagine a market is is running
higher
and you you haven't bought yet, you
know, it's a bit like Bitcoin, right?
Every day you open up you know,
CoinMarketCap Bitcoin is up. Shib Shib
coin is up, right? Everything is up. And
you want to be buying it, but you you
don't want to be buying the top.
But delta is going to help you
understand that, you know what? Even
though this market is going higher
the aggressive buying that was stronger
earlier
is
no longer as strong as it was.
All right? And why that's important is
because
imagine, right? Everybody is buying,
buying, buying, buying, but then
everybody is bought.
Well, then who's left to buy? Nobody.
The guy that bought it at the top is
holding the bag, basically. And then
what's going to happen? If there's no
more buyers, the market's just going to
naturally pull back.
So, you know, that's how
you know, delta is going to help you in
the market. Now, there there's others
more advanced ways, but you know, I just
want to give you, you know, a sort of
simple overview of different ways
delta can help you in the market. And
by understanding that, you know, delta
trading decisions
you can make based on the order flow
delta. So,
who's in control of the market? You
know, simple. Basically, you know, a
market's going up, you're seeing
positive delta, market's going down,
generally you're seeing negative deltas,
right? Big negative delta here, negative
negative, positive positive positive
as the market is moving higher, right?
Now, again, not always is it going to be
a red bar with negative delta or a green
bar with positive delta, right? Here's a
green bar with
positive delta. Here's a red bar with
negative delta. I thought there was one
here. Here's a um red bar with negative
delta. You know, Mike you might Mike you
just said, you know, delta's going to
tell me who's in control of the market.
Remember what I said about absorption.
Right? The market
bounced up here,
right? But you have offers up here,
right? You got somebody offering it out
there. Basically, you have people buying
it thinking it's going to go higher.
They're there absorbing all that
aggressive buying.
Right? But then that buying gets shut
off for whatever reason, then the market
dropped. But they bought so much up here
that you're left with that positive
delta, right? This is actually a bearish
sign in the market.
Okay? So, you know, hopefully that that
helps you understand, you know, who's in
control of the market. Okay? There's
there's
I could go more in depth on that, but
that would be, you know, that that's
just on this whole concept alone,
understanding who's in control of the
market, that that's sort of a training
by itself.
Recognizing absorption in the market,
well, how can you do that? Well, you can
use delta. Okay? So, for example, this
is a 5-minute crude oil chart.
5 minutes.
Okay? 20
You can see the volumes down here per
bar. You know, it's somewhere between
2,500 and and 5,000 contracts. So, it's
decent volume, right? And decent deltas,
you know, 600, 289, 265, 212, you know,
minus one.
So, it's a smallish delta, right? It's
Again, it's not zero. It's just minus
one.
Again,
often times, like I said, if it was just
sort of during the course of a market
moving sideways, and I see a small delta
like this 143,
I wouldn't put much into it. But then,
okay, I get up here to a swing high.
I got a small delta. It traded decent
volume, 2,800 contracts. It's about
the lower end of the average here.
Again, I'm not I don't need to calculate
three you know, this one traded 3,376,
5273,
you know, 5292.
Oh, this one's light volume. No, I I
don't need to do that, right? I could
just look at it and say, "It's within
the parameters, right? It's not 1,000.
It's 2825. So, it's decent volume. And
okay, well, why is delta so little? It's
only one." Right? Again, I would be
thinking the same thing if it was
positive five or
positive eight, you know, or minus 10.
Okay, well, the reason is
I could see in the order flow, right? I
can look at the volume that's traded on
the offer side. I say, "Oh, you know
what? That That's decent, right?"
Because normally, right? If a market's
going to sell off
quite dramatically, often times, like a
quick reversal,
you're not going to see that absorption,
right? You're just going to see
a big red candle with strong negative
delta, cuz it sort of hit that high, and
then they attracted these big sellers
coming into the market, just hit every
bid, right? And then the market just
dropped, and you end up with a bar with
a strong negative delta, you know, minus
500.
But up here near the in this bar, right?
I can see wow, this they got 120 up
here. So, I know that up here that
there's somebody just sort of
happy to sell, right? That they're
they're not necessarily showing their
hand yet up here at this 82,
you know, 60 area. They're just happy to
sit back, and you know, people want to
trade it up here, fine. I'll be happy to
sell it to them. Then, you know, as the
market starts to drop, you know, they
start to get a little bit more
aggressive. Um they're still trailing
their offers down. You can see some nice
volume coming in down here as well.
But they they are sort of hiding their
intentions in the market by keeping it
the delta small directionally.
Okay? Now again,
as I said earlier, right? A small delta
often times they're treated as neutral,
but you got to take it in context with
what's happening in the market. If you
know, like I said, this 43 that's over
here, this other bar that's got a 34,
yeah, you know, okay.
Yeah, I I don't really read too much
into it. But when you start getting up
at swing highs or swing lows, that's
when you should be paying attention
because that's where markets are going
to start to turn, you know, after a
swing high or after a swing low.
Now,
determining if a market is starting to
show strength, right? You use delta. So,
this is a market, it's crude oil.
Market's just going sideways, you know,
from 10:40 you know, to 10:55, 15
minutes, doing nothing.
All right, it looks like it's starting
to sell off here, you know,
you got some negative deltas. Now,
this is about understanding what's
happening in the market, okay? You see
this bar here, minus 91, minus 18, minus
40, all these deltas negative, minus 74,
minus 18, minus 44, minus 80, minus 158,
minus 82, minus 33. Got a lot of selling
going on. It's overall negative delta.
All right, you got one bar here with
positive delta of 18.
Got one bar here with positive delta of
61.
Okay,
fine.
But overall, majority, you know, for
every one bar that's positive delta, you
got three or four bars that's negative
delta. And then all of a sudden,
you see the market start to come to
life, 61, 135, 248.
All right, so we're starting to break
out of this sideways action.
And the aggressive buying is getting
stronger, right? Here you had aggressive
selling getting stronger, minus 44,
minus 80,
minus 158. Okay, great. Maybe this
market could finally start to sell off,
but it doesn't, right? You know, there's
a saying in the market, you know, often
what doesn't happen is just as important
as what happens.
So, you have a very strong sign of, you
know what? I got aggressive sellers
getting stronger in here.
Maybe I should look for the market to
sell off. Okay, what happens in the next
bar? Nothing. It comes right back up,
positive delta. Okay, wait for the next
bar.
Got nice negative delta minus 82. Okay,
maybe we're back on track now. Maybe
this market could finally start to sell
off.
But then the next bar, minus 33. It's a
doji candle, opens and closes at the
same price. Only goes one tick lower.
All of a sudden now, the aggressive
buying takes over.
61,
135, 248.
Right? This market is starting to show
signs of strength, right? This is
it in essence a delta surge here, right?
You had a delta surge here,
but there was no follow-through, right?
Then here, you start to see the
follow-through come in, not in the next
bar. Next bar just does nothing. It's
got a nice negative delta of 76, but it
can't get below the point of control of
the previous bar.
Doesn't go any higher. So, it's kind of,
you know,
it's a doji candle, and doji candles in
the order flow, even though there's
volume that trades,
often times
don't lean one way or the other, right?
I don't want to say I ignore them, but I
just sort of say, well, you know, I got,
you know, I I need some direction. Price
isn't giving me any direction, even
though delta's negative.
If that was market was really going to
start to sell off, I got a nice negative
76 delta, the market should start to
sell off, instead does the opposite. So,
I got aggressive buying stepping up
here.
Nothing happens in this next bar, but
then the next bar it pops up, right? How
I like to trade these type of setups is
I see the aggressive buying coming in.
You know, I all I know is okay, this is
high this bar is 88. If it trades 90,
you know, I just drop a buy stop in
here. Boom. You know, get filled 91.
92, market starts to go up. Now, traders
are putting in the effort here and
they're starting to get rewarded.
Traders put in an effort here
to sell, but they weren't getting
rewarded.
So, everyone that was selling in here is
looking for this market to go lower.
They're starting to cover here. All
right, they're starting to cover here.
And then as they're covering,
more and more traders are realizing this
market isn't going lower and they're
looking to start to get long.
This is the results, right? And first
this chart here was the effort, right?
Right here you see the 61 135 248. This
is the second half of the chart, right?
Here's the 248. This is that doji
candle. Like I said, yeah, you should be
getting long somewhere here around 92,
91 92 93.
It just basically went sideways on you
before it finally popped up all the way
up into the 20s.
Okay, this was this morning in in crude
oil.
So, again, that's how delta can help you
be positioned for a directional move.
Okay? Now, determining if a market is
weakening,
okay? Use the delta, all right? Because
after all,
what is delta?
Well, delta is
the difference between aggressive buying
and aggressive selling. So, if delta
isn't getting stronger,
then
what does that tell you about the move,
right? If a market is going up,
but delta is just is declining, then
it's not going to do much. It's not
going to go further, right? Because what
you have have now on delta that's even
though it's positive, but it's it's a
weaker positive, you have
the number of buyers is less. So, as a
result, the market still may go up a
bit, but
it's not going to keep, you know,
everyone says the market don't go up
forever. Well, it's not, right? It's
starting to slow down. It's starting to
stall. Just as if a market is selling
off, right? You see strong you know,
everyone's capitulation, you know, it's
just get me out. You see the deltas all
big negative, negative, negative as the
market is selling off.
Then as you notice, the markets will
start to form a bottom, go sideways and
go back up. But if you watch the delta,
you could you're instead of coming and
saying, "Oh my gosh, you know, everyone
is selling.
I got to sell, too." Right? But if
you're watching the delta, you're
thinking, "Well, yeah, everyone is
selling, but the selling is getting
weaker, right? Maybe I I should
you know, hold off on my on my selling
and wait for a bounce and try to, you
know, get something out of it or
possibly, you know, bottom fish." Again,
it's not about trying to pick a higher
or a low, you know, a top or bottom.
It's about
understanding what's happening in the
market. So, for example,
crude oil, right? This is this morning,
8:30, right? We we went up from
you know, basically 82.10 all the way up
to 82.60, a nice 50 cent move.
This is on in in 5 minutes, right?
And, you know, there's that expression,
FOMO, right? Fear of missing out. What
you get is you get a lot of traders
coming in. Oh, we're starting to rally.
I better buy some. I got to get in. I
got to get in.
And then what happens? It stalls out.
And then it reverses.
But if you watch the delta, 333,
364,
166,
34.
Okay? So, what's going on? Well, you got
some strong buying here,
stronger here, then weaker, then at the
high, it's your weakest positive delta.
Right? If this market's going to go
higher,
you shouldn't be looking at your weakest
delta number here, 34,
right? And even the previous bar, even
though you're you're making these
excuse me, making these new highs here.
Delta's weaker than the previous bar of
364.
So, what's that telling you? It's going
from 364 to 166 to 34 before it
eventually turned here at 70 -73.
All right, so it went
up up up,
positive, less positive, less positive,
negative. All right, sort of the
opposite of a delta surge, if you will.
What happens? The market drops from 50,
you know, back down to 20.
So,
you know, these are just examples of the
different ways that you can use
delta in your analysis.
All right, so now I'll get into the
delta scalper.
Okay, now the delta scalper runs on
NinjaTrader 8, but it takes the hard
work of analysis of order flow out of
the order flow chart for you, right? It
puts it on a normal bar chart. Now,
if you still like to use a footprint
chart, you can,
but you don't have to. You know, I I
realize a lot of people trade off bar
charts, you know, they want to keep it
clean, or they have their existing
indicators on there. That's fine, right?
You don't have to take everything you
are currently using in the market and
just chuck it out the window.
You know, what I'm saying is you just
add delta scalper to your existing
chart. And again, it runs on NinjaTrader
8. So, again, you don't have to use an
order flow footprint chart, you know? If
you have a chart that you're comfortable
with, that you've been trading with for
a long time, you could keep it, right?
You just add delta scalper to it.
Now, it's called delta scalper for a
reason, right? It's not called the delta
scalper holdler, right? You're not
reading something in the order flow
right now and holding it for a week,
right? It's designed for intraday
traders, short-term traders. You know, I
hate to use the term, you know, every
trade starts with a scalp, but you know,
every trade,
you don't know if it's going to be
going in your direction right away or
not, right?
How many times have
you know, I know this happens to me. You
get into a position and it immediately
goes against you, right? Because we
don't know what's going to happen on the
next trade or the next sec- the third
trade or the fourth trade. You don't
know as soon as you hit buy there's some
big
guy at Goldman Sachs that's got an order
to sell 5,000 e-minis, right? You just
bought one or two. Well, all of a sudden
he's got to come in and sell,
you know, 5,000, right? So,
it's about understanding you know,
what's happening in the market, but
Delta Scalper is really designed for
short-term traders.
Okay, and it's really designed for the
futures market. You know, you could use
it with stocks. Forex I don't follow.
Um, crypto,
you know, we're going to be releasing a
version of Order Flows Trader, the
footprint chart for crypto.
And, you know, to be honest,
most people that I know that trade
crypto, I don't really want to use the
term crypto. They're just holders,
right? They just buy it, forget about it
for a while. You know, they they they
look at charts, but you know,
I haven't
yet really sat down with somebody that
that's trading intraday crypto. You
know, I I tried. You know, I do
um, you know, I was testing out the new
Order Flows Trader software for
um, that runs on on crypto. And,
you know, it's it's different because
you got, you know, it's trading in
satoshis and all that.
And, if you're trading
unless you know, unless you're using
margin,
you're trading with a full, you know,
the full value,
you need to put a lot of money into it
basically to to see some decent returns
cuz
um,
you know, if you're buying $50 worth of
Bitcoin and and you you take it up a
little bit,
you get out, you know, what's your uh,
your your profit is like
a couple dollars or something like that.
You're better off trading futures. But
anyway, um
we are working on that. So again, you
know, Delta Scalper is really designed
for short-term intraday futures traders
and to a lesser extent stock traders.
Now,
I'm going to talk about the Delta
Scalper a bit here. Okay, so let me just
get my
NinjaTrader up here.
Okay, so again, this is a footprint
chart.
Okay? So everything you're seeing in
here in the footprint,
okay, with the Deltas, right? With
what's traded on the bid, what's traded
on the offer. What we've done,
okay, now there there is a calculation
that goes into the Delta Scalper, right?
Because we're measuring Delta.
Okay, so
we're putting it in context of the
markets.
You know, is this Delta
important or not? And again, like I
said, you know, not every bar's Delta is
going to be important.
Sometimes it will be,
sometimes it won't be.
It has to be taken in context of what's
happening in the market.
Okay, so what we've done is we've taken
this information that you're seeing
here, right? The bid volume, the ask
volume, the Delta, you know, put it in
context of the market over, you know,
recent market activity,
and we were able to come up with putting
it on a chart
to give you buy signals,
give you sell signals. This is a gold
chart, all right? This is
a wheat chart, all right? This is
a crude oil chart.
Okay? This is Well, that's something
else. That's the E-minis, but um
what else I got here? I got a a mini Dow
chart,
right? You see there's there's nice
moves down,
some nice little moves down, you know,
some nice move up. Again, not every
trade is going to be, you know, a big,
you know, like here, you know, every
trade is not going to be, you know, from
650 down to, you know, 550. We wish they
were. Sometimes the moves are going to
be smaller.
Like you see here, right? From basically
from, you know, 85
you know, up to
you know, 700. Right? Or this move here
from
um 60, you know, down to basically,
well, this is what? 40 here.
You know, sometimes you can only get 20
points out of a move. Sometimes you can
only get 15 points. And other times it's
going to give you an opportunity to get
more. You know, this is a move from
you know, 15 all the way up to 100, you
know, 715.
And, you know, and depending on the type
of chart, you know, sometimes you're
going to be catch these beautiful moves
like this one in the crude,
you know, from 56, 54,
you know, down into the down into the
20s.
Right? This is a a tick-based chart.
These are minute-based charts.
Now,
when we created the Delta Scalper,
really what we're looking for is rises
or declines in the delta. Okay? But not
just every rise or every decline. It's
got to happen in context of the market,
right? And it's got to happen in context
with how the market was just trading.
Okay? Cuz, you know, just saying, "Oh,
you know, here I've got, you know, I've
got delta. It it jumped from 52 to 300,
you know, -52 to +300. That's a buy."
Well, no. Okay? It's not going to say
that, "Oh, it it's, you know, it's
jumping, you know, up and down." Because
it's not going to be consistent cuz
there's going to be a lot of times where
you have bars with small delta than a
bars with a big delta.
Okay? Cuz remember,
it's based on what's trading in the
market.
And sometimes the market is quiet,
right? And it's just not going to trade
a lot of volume.
Okay, so that's why you have to take it
in context of what's happening in the
market.
You know, this is
um
you know, here like sometimes it goes
from big positive to a big negative.
Well, what does that mean, right? It
means something
and unless you understand how to read
the delta, you're going to miss, you
know, opportunities like this where the
delta changes all of a sudden.
Right? Because, you know, maybe you're
just not familiar with it, right? If you
want to take the time to learn it,
you can.
Right? Cuz all this stuff is is
learnable, but why not just take a have
an indicator
that's going to give you a sign say,
"Hey, you know what?
Delta's bullish here.
Delta's bullish here. Delta's bullish
here. Delta was negative here."
Okay? You know, you
there are going to be trades that
get stopped out like this one right here
or this one here.
Okay? Imagine you you you get stopped
out here, you get maybe get stopped out
here, then you get long here.
7720.
Could trade all the way up,
you know, to 84 before you get, you
know, a bearish sign in the market.
And you know, this is just this is this
morning in in gold. I mean, look at
this. All on this move down, you can see
you know, people say, "Well, you had to
buy here and it didn't work out." Okay,
well, it came right back with a nice
sell here, another short here, another
short here, nice beautiful short right
here.
You know, before the market just crapped
out.
But
why try to sit there
spend the time analyzing the footprint
when you can have software that's going
to to do it for you.
So, I'll just take you through the
settings real quick cuz I want you to
see how easy and and simple this is, how
we've made it for you so that could just
start seeing results
well Monday basically when the market
reopens is this is the
settings right very simple very easy
layout the license token right that's
where you enter your
token
you know when when if you purchase the
software you enter it right here right
and then and some people
yeah even though I sit there and I
create videos and I take screenshots and
you know put it in the user guide saying
hey put it in there you know they they
they they
they don't want to follow you know it
doesn't go under here under
license key or third-party licensing
etc. It goes in here in the actual
indicator setting right so once you open
up the indicator once you add it to
NinjaTrader as you would any other
indicator takes about 15 seconds
you open it up you find it in here under
available indicators Delta Scalper make
sure it shows up here you drop your
license token in there.
Simple.
Okay and again if you don't get your
license token
you don't see it in your email check
your spam folder as well sometimes you
know people's things get sent to spam
sometimes you know sometimes I I send
emails to myself to remind me of things
you know my wife says oh you got to buy
tickets to the show for the kids
then okay so you know I'll send myself
an email to you know cuz I'll be out or
something and on my phone and I'll go
where's my email I check my spam and it
ended up in there for some reason.
Now the trade entry signal okay this is
one of the new features right I said
Delta Scalper's been around for
a while but this is one of the new
additions that we put in the the Delta
Scalper is the trade entry signal and
what this does is one of you have a
choice to enable it or disable it.
When enabled the Delta Scalper is only
going to signal
trades after the market conditions are
met and
the market moves in the direction of the
signal signal by at at two ticks over
the next two bars. That's what price
level in ticks is two.
Trade validity in bars is two. Now
again, you could say, "Ah, it's only got
to move one tick
in the direction of the signal." Okay,
fine. You change that to one. You say,
"I want to give it a few more bars than
two, right? I'll give it five." The max
you can put in is five.
Um so, as long as it moves one tick in
the direction
over the next five bars, okay. Now some
people will say, "No, no, I want it to
move immediately." You know, it's I I
know some traders that say, "You know
what, you Mike, with the order flow, it
has to move immediately." So, what they
do is they change it to say one tick
and one bar. So, it's it has to move
immediately in the next bar, right? They
cuz just because
you know, they found their their based
on their settings and the way they use
the tool,
is the best trades for them are the ones
that happen right now.
So, for example, um I'll just show you
the difference here. Let me get my my
chart up.
Okay, so you know, I'm just going to
show you guys on on a um
on a bar chart, right? Just cuz it's
it's a bit easier.
So, you'll notice here, right? There's
a triangle. That's the signal.
The signal, the signal, the signal.
Now you'll notice there's some boxes
here, here. This is just telling you
I'll which I'll get to the setting in a
mo- moment.
Conditions are met,
but
it didn't move the required amount of
ticks over the next the immediate um
bars. So, what that means is
this one is set to two and two. So,
you have a signal here because this was
the signal bar.
And then,
it moved two ticks over the next two
bars. That's where this signal printed,
right? It didn't print on the signal
bar, it printed on the actual bar. Now
if you have this enabled,
as soon as it prints, it will not
repaint.
Okay? And that's important because
for example
if
you are using if you're not using the
trade entry signal as soon as the
conditions are met in the bar, it will
give you the down triangle.
And
if the bar is not closed yet, meaning
you know, if it's a 1-minute bar and
you're 40 seconds into the bar and
you've got a signal, but then the last 5
seconds everything changes in the bar
and what was very bearish earlier
dis- dissipates, it goes away, the
signal will go away. But then once the
bar closes, if there's a signal there,
it will stay there. If there's not it
won't appear. But it can change as the
bar is forming. Okay, but if you That's
if you're not using the trade entry
signal. If you're using the trade entry
signal, it's only going to appear
when those conditions are met.
Now, for example here, right? Trade
entry signal is
on. So, if I disable it, okay?
Notice there's no trade entry here,
right? There's no buy signal here,
right? There's no sell and no buy
at this top here and this blue here. But
if I disable it
Okay, so there was that
blue box here, but there was no blue
triangle here. There was a red box up
here, but there was no
red triangle. So, when you disable it
it's just going to give you the signal
as long as the conditions are met.
Right? So, you can see the sell here,
the buy here. The buy here.
The buy here. Now people say, "Well, you
know, Mike, do I do I really need to use
it?" Well, again, you don't have to. I
like to use it because I want the order
flow to confirm
the signal.
Right? There needs to be follow-through
order flow. So, imagine if you're using
it versus you're not using it. If you've
ever gone over your trade um results,
right? Keep track of your trades,
you know, look at your winners and
losers.
Imagine
you could cut out this losing trade
right here,
right? You could cut out this trade.
Now, maybe this trade would have stopped
you out as it came back up here. Maybe,
maybe not.
Maybe this one would have stopped you
out, right? This one over here
would have stopped you out. Imagine you
could take out this losing trade,
this losing trade,
how much difference
your trading results are going to be.
So, say you had 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 9 potential trades,
of which this was a loser,
this was a loser,
this was a loser. You could
take away those three right off the bat.
So, you have one
two
three four five trades instead. Okay,
because you took out this other one.
You still have the big winner.
This one, well, you should have already
been short. I'm not going to say you
should should have gotten short here
because it's already happened in this
downtrend. You should have been short
here.
Then you got one loser.
We'll call this one a loser
for what it's worth.
Call this one a winner because it did go
down. Didn't stop you out here. It came
back down before it sort of worked its
way back up. Maybe you could have
scratched this. Maybe you could have
made um you know, a few ticks.
But you took out this losing trade here.
You took out this losing trade and
potentially this losing trade, right?
Imagine how your results are going to
change
if you could start removing some of
these losing trades. So, that's how the
trade entry signal
is going to help you. Okay? Now, into
the actual settings, okay?
The look back bars. It determines how
many bars back to go in the analysis.
Now, you don't need to go over 10.
A value of zero would disable the look
back bar setting, okay? Before we didn't
have it where you could enter zero. We
had another
thing down here, signal only on higher
high or lower low,
which
I'll get to later, but if you were to
disable this, it basically disables the
look back bars and makes it a zero. Now,
I suggest settings of 1 3 5 or 7. Again,
you could use whatever. There's no point
in going over 10. That's That's just too
far back.
Um
and sometimes I use zero, right? Some
markets I like to use zero because I
just want to see every signal that comes
up.
Okay? So, again, it depends on your
trading style, how you approach the
markets.
Now, the main settings is this, the
Delta Scalper strength, negative Delta
strength, positive Delta strength.
Okay, this is the most important
setting.
The minimum strength level is one. You
can't put zero in cuz
strength is zero, you then you wouldn't
use the indicator, right? So, it's got
to be at least one.
Now, a level of two is double the
strength of level one.
A level of three
is actually four times the strength. So,
the higher the numbers you go,
you basically you're doubling it and
doubling it and doubling it. Now, you
can go above three, but honestly, you
won't get many signals. Once you get
above three, it's really just too too
strong and you won't get enough signals
to
make it effective. You'll get You will
see some,
but sometimes when, you know, you you
people say, "Oh, I want to put 10 in
there because, you know, I I only want
the the strongest signals." Well,
you know, you don't have to because
sometimes
you're going to get these bursts and
Deltas if,
you know, a a customer, meaning, you
know, a a
hedge fund or
somebody say, "Oh, you know, I got to
get out of my my position." And they
just chuck an order into the market,
tell the executing trader at the bank or
wherever, "Just get me out." They don't
care about the price and then you just
see this burst order go through the
market and that's it. It's not really
indicative of the market. And if you go
above 10, sometimes you're going to get
caught in
those types of orders.
Now, signal box height
is
how
um
Uh where's my NinjaTrader here? Is is
basically
how tall to draw this box, right? It's
in ticks. Okay, so two, you don't need
to adjust that. You can just keep it at
two.
The opacity is how dark or light you
want to draw that zone, right? That box.
25 is good. Um you don't want to make
it, you know, 100 so so dark that you
can't see anything on your chart.
Especially if you got other tools, you
know, it might might cover up something
that matters to you. So, you know, 25 is
good. Now, the zone you can disable,
right? Say you don't want to use the
zones, right? I like to use the zones
because
um
it basically tells me,
right?
That if it like for example here, right?
The sell, okay? I know I'm short. I
should be getting short in here, but if
it starts trading back above this zone,
this tell me the order flow has changed,
right? You don't want to be in that
position anymore. You should think of
getting out.
You know, for example, um
you know, just
like
here, right? As as soon as I go, you
know, you're getting long,
you go in market's going up, it starts
trading back into that zone, definitely
be looking for the exit door, right? Cuz
once it gets beyond that zone,
then all bets are off,
right? I said the best trades are the
ones that happen right away.
So, you can disable that, right? If you
don't want to use those zones. Like here
is this is the wheat chart with it
disabled, right? You don't see the
zones, you just see the buy or sell
signals.
Let me drink some water here, guys.
You know, if you want to have a clean
chart, if you want to throw it into
something like markers,
right, which will automate these signals
for you,
you can you know, you don't need to have
the zones drawn in there, right? You
could have them
not shown on your chart.
Now, the next one is the signal mark
displacement. It's just basically how
far above
the bar for a sell or how far below
the bar for a buy to plot the signal,
right? Um
it will
yeah, two is fine. You know, you don't
need to put it so far away.
Uh you know, it it's just I I'm
you don't need to change that at all.
Now, the last one, like I said, is this
one signal only.
Um
on higher higher higher low, this is
related to the set setting up here, look
back bars, okay? If you uncheck this
box, basically you're disabling the
entire look back bars to begin with.
I said in previous version, we couldn't
set it to zero. Um I I asked my
programmer to make that change. He left
this in um cuz some people are so used
to it, but you could actually set the
look back bars to zero, which would
disable it.
But, it's just best to keep it enabled.
Now, the next set of
settings here, data series set up,
visuals, you don't need to change this,
you know, don't even touch any of the
you know, this is just the input series.
Like in this example, this is crude I'm
looking at. It's calculated on each
tick. The label that you're going to see
on the top of the chart is the order
flows delta scalper. Maximum look back
bars is 256, which is standard. The
visual auto scale, you know, this is how
your chart is going to look.
Same as input series, you don't need it
put it below the chart or anything.
Um scale justification is based off the
right, you know, and make sure it's
visible. Okay? So, you don't need to
touch any of the data series set up or
visuals. Just leave those.
Now, the plots,
positive delta change, which is buys,
negative delta change, which is sells,
is set the blue triangle up and it's
it's eight pixels. So, again, you don't
need to change those unless you have
some other indicator that's using the
exact same ones, right? But you can
change it to, you know, say you don't
like the color, you know, say, "Ah, you
know what? Like I I I got something else
that's using red. Um I I I need a
different color. Okay, well, you just go
in here, open it up, change
change to whatever color you want to
use, you know, yellow something. I
depends on what you want to use it, you
know, what other color you want to use.
You just change it. See, you can see
it's hard to see right now, but there's
a yellow um
personally I find red or dark red is
fine.
You know, same thing with buys, right?
Say you got some other indicator that
gives blue buy signals. Well, you can
change it from blue to, you know, green
or aqua or any other color. Yeah, you
can also change say you don't want to
use triangle up, you know, you want to
use something else, you know, line or a
hash or a dot or a cross. You can do
that, but, you know,
I I just find it easier to keep a
triangle up, triangle down. You can
change the size. Say you know, eight is
too big for you, you want a smaller
size, you can adjust that. Um you know,
eight I find is is nice. Some people
like to use 12. Some people like to use
four. Really depends on you um and and
what you want to use. So, like I said,
you know, we we've purposely kept the
the settings simple because, you know,
we don't want people really going in
there and changing a lot of different
settings
and not understanding what they're
changing, you know, you look at a lot of
other indicators on the market, you
know, the free ones that come with the
NinjaTrader. There's all things you can
change, but people don't understand what
they're changing changing in all
honesty.
So,
Delta Scalper is created to make delta
analysis easier.
Okay, that's why we don't have too many
moving parts, right? It all moves on the
back end, not the front end. So, you
don't have to deviate much in the
settings, right? All you really need to
focus on is strength,
negative delta strength or positive
delta strength, and the look back.
Now, I'll give you a few settings here,
okay? I'm just going to talk about it.
This is this area up here. Look back
bars zero, negative delta strength one,
positive delta strength one. Generally,
you're going to keep
I should highly suggest, I won't say
generally,
the negative delta strength and the
positive delta strength the same, right?
You you're probably going to want to
keep it one and one or two and two.
You're not going to go one and three or
three and one. I mean, you can,
then, you know, you'd sort of be leaning
saying, "Well, you know, I think, you
know, I want to see more aggressive
buying than aggressive
selling." But, it's just
keep them equal. I mean, in the sense of
if you're using one for negative delta
strength, then you're going to want to
use one for positive delta strength,
like that, okay?
Now, look back is zero. So, let's just
take a look
at how it looks on the chart, okay? So,
when when you set the look back to zero,
basically, you're telling the chart to
give you every signal that appears. So,
um
well,
what is this? Wheat. Uh I don't want to
use wheat cuz I know it's not everybody
trades wheat. Not everybody is a wheat
trader. So,
go back to our
crude oil chart. So, this one I know is
set to a look back period of seven,
okay? So, it's going over the last seven
bars and analyzing that deltas and
market structure. If I change it to
zero, if I disable the look back,
okay?
I should see more buy signals, more sell
signals. Now, I do have the trade entry
signal enabled here.
Okay?
So, you can see here it's calculating.
Now, I know
zero one one.
And then, these others, the 2252, is
these other settings here, the height,
the width, opacity,
etc. So, you can see now
right, there's more
blue boxes, more red boxes, right? Not
necessarily more signals.
Right? If you go back here, right now
I'm seeing basically every signal that's
met
and the trade entry signal conditions
are met.
Right? So, I'm seeing more buys,
more sells.
Okay?
But, I'm still seeing the boxes. Again,
I could remove these boxes, but again, I
like to use it as my guide to tell me,
you know what? This trade is if it
starts trading into those boxes in the
other side, the trade is breaking down.
Okay? So, that's zero
one one.
Okay? So, basically no look back
and uh strength of one
positive and negative. Now, the next one
that, you know, I suggest people try is
one one and one. One look back
strength is one and one. Okay? And on on
a chart
now it's it's going back over the
previous bar, okay? The the initial bar
as well as the previous bar
and it's basically comparing deltas and
order flow. Okay? So,
let's take a look here. Let's make this
I'll see if I I'll keep this up here.
So, you can see, right? I'm going to
change this to one. Right? So, you're
seeing there's
buys buys buys,
these sells,
some buys, etc.
Now, if I hit apply,
okay? It's going to change it, right?
There's going to be less signals cuz now
I'm taking into account
the when you use zero, it's not taking
into account the previous bar. When you
use one,
it is starting to take into account the
previous order flow. So, now you're
seeing a few less signals here, right?
Before there was a few buys on the way
up. Now, you're just seeing the one
here, one here
as far as using the trade entry signal.
Okay.
Now, another one,
the 5 1 and 1. So, a little bit more
stricter on the look back. When I say
stricter, it means it's taking into
account
more order flow, okay?
And why would you want to do that? You
know, depending on the market,
you know, you're going to want to see,
you know, some market movement before
you
take a trade. Well, honestly, that's not
the way way to put it. Um when you're
using the look back of five, you're
taking into account more order flow into
the signal.
Okay?
So, let's set the five. Now, earlier I I
had this start up, it was at seven,
right? So, five,
you're going to see a little bit less
signals than
when I had one, right? So, you see here,
there's just a buy signal here, the sell
signal here,
right? And then, obviously, this one is
still the same, that's there. Again,
what if I have it set at one,
you're going to see, you know, a buy
signal up here.
I think there was a sell signal over on
this left-hand side.
Just give it a second. Yeah, so.
All right, you see this sell signal
here.
There was a
buy signal up here.
All right, but if you have it set to
five,
All right, so I'm changing it to five.
That sell signal here is gone. That
buy signal a little bit higher
is also gone.
All right, so it sort of cleans up the
chart a little bit more because when I
say it's a little bit stricter on the
order flow, is it's it's conditions got
to be met over a longer period.
Okay. Now, another setting, again, I'm
not going get into too many different
settings, but
a little bit stronger this time. So, I'm
going to go zero look back anytime the
conditions are met
and the trade entry signal is enabled.
But, the strength this time is going to
be two, all right, for both positive and
negative. Again, you know, there's not
really a point in setting it at zero and
or one and two. You know, but you want
to keep it the same.
Um
Okay, so
let's just adjust this to zero, two, and
two. So, I'll change the look back to
two, zero. But, again, you know, these
are just guidelines. I don't like to
tell people, you know, you got to use
this setting or you got to use that
setting.
Because everybody trades differently,
all right? They all have different
outlooks of the market, you know, time
frames. So, maybe you don't use a tick
chart, maybe you use a minute-based
chart. Or maybe you use a volume-based
chart or, you know, range-based chart.
So, it really depends on on sort of how
you're you're trading. So, here's a
little bit stronger, but now, you know,
you're missing certain signals, all
right, that that you had before.
Earlier, you had a sell here when it's
set to one. You jack up the strength to
That's too strong. It just doesn't
qualify,
all right?
But, again, you know, depending on the
market that you're trading,
you know, you might want to use it, all
right? Or earlier in the day, there was
some nice buys here on the way up, some
small sells.
Um you know,
sell here, buy here, buy here. Again, so
it really depends on on how you want to
use it, all right, on on the strength.
And you know, your your own
personal trading that goes on.
All right, because again, not everybody
has the same risk tolerance levels. And
not everybody trades the same chart
type.
But, again, there's not many things you
really got to change, right? You should
basically you're dealing with the look
back, you want to use it or not. You're
dealing with the the delta strength,
you know, whether it's one and one or or
two and two. You know, for example, all
these charts that I had
open
here.
This is wheat. This is the same one one
and one.
Right? Look back one
strength
negative one strength positive one one
one and one.
Okay? This is mini Dow.
One one and one.
One one one.
Again, you know, trading with order flow
again, people have this misconception
with order flows is got to give them
every single turning point in the
market. It order flow is not going to do
that.
Right? But it's going to give you
turning points
in the market.
And your job is a trader, right? You
still got to manage the trade, you know,
once you're in it. Sometimes you're
going to get
small trades here, like this one and
this one.
You know, there's other times you're
going to get big runners like this one.
It really depends on the market
conditions.
All right? Sometimes you're going to
catch this big move here.
Right? You're going to catch a move
here, right? Trailing your stop, you
know, you know, this came you know, you
just had that push after the cash open,
which sucked. Then shot up. You know,
these are the worst ones where it just
sort of comes in, pushes down, stops you
out, then makes that move. But you know,
here's a nice move here.
Okay? So there's there's a lot of
different
ways you can use it in the market,
right? Here, same settings, exact same
settings, one one and one.
Right? That I showed you on the wheat
chart that I showed you on the mini Dow
chart. Um I showed you on the crude
chart. You know, this is gold.
Right? One one and one. Yeah, we all
love these trades where the market just
drops here, you know, from 1794
all the way down to, you know,
74 or something or you know, this is
what 80.
Sometimes, you know, it takes the market
a long way to get there.
Okay?
But really as as a trader, you know,
you're you're you're a grinder, right?
You're you try to grind out the wins.
You know, the nice trades that happen
here. This is the evening session
European session here.
All right? You know, I sent out an email
earlier this week about the Asian
session.
Right? There's moves to be had here in
during Asia, right? This is 9:00.
You know, from 97 up to 99, you know, at
11:00. Yeah, yeah, you get stopped out
here. You can take a small loss, but
then you get a nice trade coming on in
here from 97, you know, all the way down
to 96.
Sorry, 95 rather. Nice move from 97 to
96. It's not much of a move. But, um you
know, there's moves to be had in these
sessions,
right? And even if you get stopped out,
it's not a big stop, right? It's
manageable.
All right. So,
you know, I'm going to open it up to
some questions and answering here, okay?
So, I'm going to go through
um
some of these setting uh questions here.
Uh take off my glasses here.
Um
Okay, here.
Yeah, uh maybe this you know, the
market's closed when Thomas says
CMO Chandler Mahindra oscillator.
Yeah. Um
that's what the CMO indicator is. Maybe
the zero the market is closed. No, if if
delta is zero, well, if there's no
trading, obviously delta is going to be
zero, but you know, when the market is
open, sometimes you you get bars Let me
get the uh
footprint here. Sometimes you're going
to get bars where just
it's it's zero.
Um
Let's see if I could find one here. If
there was one in the crude this morning.
Yeah, this bar right here, right? See
the delta. Traded 254 contracts, delta
was zero.
Okay? other times it's going to be small
like this five and eight. It's just
coincidence more. Um
Okay Thomas, yeah. I'll show E-minis as
the market in the last hour of trading
as the market was going up. Sure, let me
get uh
E-minis here.
Give it a second.
Um Delta Scalper for Sierra Charts, I
don't have it. There's a version
uh from Emoji Trading for Sierra Charts.
I used to have a working relationship
with Lee from Emoji. Uh we don't work
together anymore. He still has my
indicators up there.
He's made some changes I think to it.
I've made changes to mine since we've
we've talked. So, what you're seeing on
this presentation um is is probably
going to be slightly different even
though the the general architecture is
the same. Um Lee's made sort of his own
uh changes to it um from
from what
was originally released uh years ago.
Um
Marco, yeah, if you have an earlier
version
you can get an update to the new
version.
Uh
okay, so this is E-minis. This is a
one-minute chart. Let me clean this up a
little bit here.
And so I'm going to take off this bid
volume, the ask volume
just because it's a little
Actually, you know what? I could
probably just
Or I could just show you on a bar chart
um with the Delta Scalper. It's way
easier. Let me close this down.
Let's give it a second here.
So again, you know, it's sometimes it's
now it's 4:10.
Yeah, just give it a second here for
this chart to come up.
This is not my normal PC I'm doing this
presentation off of
uh, my laptop, so it's it's
it's good. It's not as powerful, you
know, but I'm running the webinar
software as well as NinjaTrader.
Um, but anyway, let me just go over to
this
uh,
the
I can cover more ground on on a
on this chart here. So, yeah, as you can
see the market in the E-minis
yeah, it it shot up. We sort of had this
little double bottom happen here around
uh, two, what is that? 220?
230?
Um, now up here in the corner you see it
said upper left-hand corner says
calculating, so it's going through the
calculations. Now, this setting is one
one and one, okay? So, it's got a look
back of one.
It's got a um,
positive and negative strength
of one.
Now, for again, you know, depending on
type of chart that you're looking at,
you might want to use zero two and two.
Maybe you want to use uh, five one and
one, okay? So,
here let's open it up.
This was that move up, all right? It
gave you this buy signal in this bar.
This was at 237.
Um,
you know, it shot up, you know,
basically from this area. What is that?
87 and a half? 88?
You know, up to the 90s you got a sell
signal here. Now, again, you're running
into the cash close, 3:00 right here.
It Do you Do you want to be holding it
into the cash close is another story,
you know, it's it's There's a nice
little move here
to be had.
And
again, you know,
that's if you're using one one and one.
Again, if you have a different setting,
say um, you know, you want to use
zero, right? Zero look back. You know, I
don't need a look back. Just give me a
retrace that happens
and it starts to move in my direction
um just change it to to zero, right? You
can even change the
price level in ticks from two to one or
you could even disable the the trade
entry signal all together if you want.
All right, give it a second. You can see
up here it says calculating. So, it's
going through the sort of the historical
data, but obviously in real time it's
just it's just constantly updating um
once you open up your chart with the
indicator on there, you just run it and
it's uh
pretty simple to use.
Yeah, there's going to be recording.
Um
Which markets are great for the Delta
Scalper?
Well, again, it depends on you. So,
here's
look back is set to zero. Um you still
got those same buys, but now you got
these couple of sells coming in as the
market sort of falls down a little bit
um and goes back up.
Which market, you know, the main markets
are fine. Honestly,
me personally,
think of it this way, you know,
you can E-minis
are the major market, right? That's what
everybody loves to trade. You know,
that's where everyone is involved in the
markets,
but there's a lot of other markets out
there, right? You don't need to stick to
E-minis, right? Cuz there's there's a
lot of I I don't like to use the term
noise. There's a lot of volume in the
market for a lot of other reasons. Often
times I find when, you know, trading
markets like some of the commodity
markets, wheat, crude oil, things that,
you know, people are buying because they
have a need. You know, a lot of people
that trade S&P's, they're just
speculating, you know, but other
markets, you know, wheat, for example,
okay, this is wheat. Um
soybeans.
You know, people are like, "Ah, yeah, I
don't want to trade wheat. You know,
it's not glamorous. You know, what am I,
a farmer or something?" But, you know, a
move from here,
you know, it wheat trades in quarters.
so a
a tick is 12 and 1/2 bucks, which is
you know, what an E-mini is worth,
right? So, from 766 to 766 and a
quarter,
that's 1250, okay? 766 to 767, that's
$50. That's one point in the S&P's. But,
you get nice moves. You know, 760 all
the way up in here,
sorry, 766 up to 771, that's five point
moves, $250.
All right?
And
you know, it it follows the order flow
nicely. This is it. 1:00 in the morning.
All right?
Minis,
you know, if you compare with minis at
at 1:00 in the morning, oftentimes,
it looks like a
you know, it
you get a lot of this, you know,
up and down, up and down, up down,
right?
So, again, you know, it depends on
the type of chart that you're trading as
well, right? This is a one-minute chart,
right? Say you want to trade
I don't know, a tick chart, 50 tick
chart,
okay?
You can do that, right? Look at this.
This is a 50 tick chart. You get some
small stop outs here and there, but you
catching, you know, most of the move,
right? This was today.
That's overnight. This is yesterday,
right?
Okay, you catching a nice little move up
here, you get stopped out here, fine.
You got a little move here, maybe you
break even, you get long here, all
but then you got the short signal here,
771.
All the way down to
what is that? 769. Okay, you get long,
you get stopped out, you get short again
here, a nice little move down.
You get a long signal here. It's just,
you know, it really depends, you know, I
just find
you know, different markets, you know,
you're going to look at them
differently.
Sort of find, you know, how you're
you're what what type of chart that
you're trading, whether it's a
1-minute chart, whether it's a a
tick-based chart, or volume-based chart.
You know, you don't need to necessarily
deviate much, you know, in the settings.
Again, this is a settings of one one and
one.
All right?
Whether Okay, so that's Oh, how about um
I don't know. Let's take a look at Euro
currency with the same settings, one one
and one. This is that's like your
starting point. Okay?
You you can go from there and sort of
break it down. Because again, you know,
I'm showing you on a 1-minute chart, you
know, on on a tick-based chart.
Maybe you use a different type of chart.
Maybe you use a 5-minute chart. Maybe
you use a 2-minute chart. Look at this.
This is Euro currency today.
All right? You had a buy signal up here
on the left. Okay, that didn't work out,
but it came in a nice sell signal here.
Nice drop. Okay? You got a buy, you get
long. Okay, you get stopped out here.
Get short again. All right? Then down
here, you get long again.
So, you can see it's it's giving you
Sorry, I got a cough here.
Excuse me.
You know, depending on on the type of
chart that you're trading,
start with one one and one and go from
there.
Excuse me.
Will
I didn't see your email. I'll I'll
double-check.
Um
Hang on. I got to drink something.
Uh sorry, I'm just going to read through
some questions here.
I'm going to pop a cough drop here.
Jared asks about uh
power bars. Yeah, I sent your email I
saw your email earlier. I'll I'll
respond to that one.
I actually won't get to it right now. Um
I I
didn't uh
reply cuz I was busy getting ready for
this, but I I want to get to it um this
evening.
Um
And Will, I'm going to check check for
your email. Um
Uh Bob asks, yeah, you know Bob, I I saw
your email also. Um
You know,
you there's a purchase code with
instructions how to download into
NinjaTrader 8. Yeah, if if you're
familiar with NinjaTrader, it's
basically it's the same way
the way you install any
any indicator into um NinjaTrader. So,
let me just uh pull up the
the thing here.
Okay, so if you have NinjaTrader up,
right?
To install it, all you do is you go to
tools,
import,
NinjaScript add-on.
Actually, there's
I got a video on the
Yeah, like after you purchase, there's
like a
a video
on how to do it. So, you just click on
it,
right? It's going to ask you to Well,
this one says already exists cuz I
already have it on there. You just click
yes, right? So, cuz
it will say, do you want to install
Ninja uh Delta Scalper onto your PC?
Replace existing file.
In this case, it says replace existing
file because it's already installed
here, but if it wasn't, then you just
you just go through the simple um
setup.
It
Yeah, I'm just go you know, I have
there's a
There's a user guide here, okay? Um
I don't know if it has it in there
on the actual importing it. There's cuz
there's something you got to know about
tick replay, right? You're going to need
to use tick replay. Okay? That's
important.
It's in the user guide. Let's the the
importing There's should be a video. Let
me see if I have the video here for you.
Uh
You know, when you
purchase the indicator, right? You're
sent to a
welcome email. Now, it's about entering
your license token. Yeah, honestly, it
it's it's really simple to install. It's
you just install it as as you would any
other indicator onto NinjaTrader. Now,
tick replay Let me talk about tick
replay real quick here.
When you open up a chart, right? You
open up a chart,
you have this thing that says tick
replay. Okay? You can see it's enabled.
If you don't have that enabled, it won't
show up, right? Cuz it's not reading the
historical data. You're not using the
tick the historical data. Then that was
the big difference between NinjaTrader 7
and NinjaTrader 8 was the ability
to use the actual
um historical data when you
install NinjaTrader. Now, if you don't
have that button, you just go to
options, and this is explained in the
user guide under market data.
You see it says here show tick replay.
If that isn't disabled,
right? You see I just disabled it.
And you click on new, right? And you
open up a new chart
whatever your currency. It doesn't have
that
market replay here.
Okay?
So, if you don't have that set up, you
just go into the tools options.
Market data.
Show tick replay. Click apply. Now, you
don't need to use level two. It's just a
simple level one data. Well, it'll
suffice.
Okay. So, here. All right. Well,
whatever you open up, now it's there.
Tick replay. You just make sure it's
enabled on the charts that you open.
Unfortunately, you got to do it for
every chart that you open.
But, you know, once I do you know, what
I do is once I have a chart that I like
with the settings that I like, I just go
down to the bottom, the tabs,
duplicate in new tab, and it just copies
over all the settings
into the new um into the new chart, you
know, then I could just go in and
change, you know, from whatever say I
you know, I don't know I want to look at
the
E-minis, you know, I want to open up a a
different chart. That's how I do it.
Um
the
it it will run on the free version of
NinjaTrader. Again, you know, this is my
laptop. This is not my normal
PC for trading. This is the free version
that I'm running it on. Okay, so it'll
run on the free version. It Honestly, if
if you want to trade through
NinjaTrader, yeah, spend the money to
get the the paid version of
of NinjaTrader. Otherwise,
um you could use the free version of
NinjaTrader. You are going to need a
data feed though, of course, all right,
live data
for it to to run.
And, you know, say you're using
whatever, you know, Infinity or AMP or
something, and you're using a different
platform to enter your trades, you can
do that. Again, you know, I know people
I have customers that use these
indicators.
They trade overseas. They just get their
data from
the data provider.
You know, they pay for it. You have to
pay for it your data.
But they're entering it on a different
system. Okay?
Because
they they they their Ninja Trader
doesn't connect to that exchange that
they're they're trading on.
Um
Yeah, it is it's going to be recorded.
It is being recorded. So, uh
Yeah, Brian. The delta is, you know, it
it's interesting because you know, like
I said, there's a lot of different order
flow indicators out there. I I've got a
few.
More than a few.
And some are trend reversals.
Some are momentum
uh indicators.
And some are combination. Okay? So, for
example,
Now, there there's times where, you
know, that that's sort of how we use the
you know, the the look back in a sense
is
Okay, here I have it turned off to to
zero, right? Now, if if I really wanted
to find sort of trend reversals,
right?
Then I'll use a look back.
Okay?
Because now I'm going back if I have
look back turned off. This is sort of a
a a
a
simple way of
either looking for momentum, you know,
momentum or every signal, right? Is I
turn the look back off. If I want to
find turning points in the market, now
again, it's not going to give me every
turning point in the market.
Right? I'll I'll use a look back of, you
know, whatever, seven or say even one.
You know, I'll I'll call it, you know,
I don't know, two.
Okay? We'll see, you know, it's going to
take off some of these other signals in
here.
Because now, instead of just looking at
the delta
in one point, it's
taking out um you know, it's looking at
um you know, more
of the order flow.
So, you can see here, right? I have the
look back set to two. So, now you're
seeing less signals. You
If if I set it to seven, or we'll call
it nine. You know, I used to use nine a
lot.
Um
Again, you don't necessarily need to go
over 10. Now, really what I'm looking
for is
you know, basically potential
turning points in the market, right? So,
set to nine. So, okay, I got a trade
here, a small stop out here. You get
stopped out a little bit here and here.
I catch a nice move up here, right? I
don't I don't know what
you know, how it looks at you know, this
other stuff, right? So,
I'm catching this move here,
right? And get another signal here, some
more sell signals here. Again, this is
you know, 1-minute chart uh excuse me, a
1-minute chart. Now,
maybe I don't want to use this a setting
of one and one, right? If I'm trying to
be so strict and and looking for
potential turning points, you know, I
could change it to two and and two, you
know, which would be
um
you know, even stronger, okay?
Now,
would I use two and two in every market?
No. Honestly, I probably use two and two
on markets that
are a bit more volatile.
Um you know, here, you know, you still
get that nice sell signal here. You're
getting some little buy here. This buy
sort of sputters and goes nowhere.
Um if I'm using two and two, I honestly
I'd I'd probably use it during the main
session than the overnight session.
Cuz I'm really trying to be, you know,
in market like gold. Let's see gold
with two and two.
You know, people will say, "What about
Nasdaq?" All right, "What about MNQ?"
Well,
And think you need to refine it. I I
don't
actively follow those markets much
anymore.
Um
just be you know, so you you you got to
sell off here, you got to sell off here,
you got to rally here. Okay?
So if I'm using two and two, I'm really
focusing on the main session. So here's
9 2. It found this turning point, right?
It didn't find this one and this one cuz
it's now it's a lot stricter,
right? If I were to set it to one,
but by setting it to zero, then it's
it's more
I don't want to say momentum. It it's
more you're going to be more active in
your trades and it's going to find, you
know, um
obviously the momentum trades, right?
Cuz it's it's not looking for
necessarily for swing highs or or swing
lows, right? So now I can catch this
trade here. I can catch this trade down.
I can catch this trade up. Catch you
know, get stopped out here. Catch this
trade up.
Little back and forth here. This trade
down, right? So it's
Again, it's it depends on um
how you want to use it.
Do you have any indicators for
range-bound charts?
No, not Well, I have turns. Um
that that's a different indicator. I
don't know if I got it on this PC or
Yeah.
Turns is completely different indicator.
Runs on different settings.
Um
but it's turns is something that's
that's more
when you know, when when you think of
range-bound, I think of more of support
and resistance, right? A market trading
around support and resistance
as opposed to
um you know, trying to find things in
momentum. But anyway,
I'm not going to cover it much here, but
there there is this indicator called
um
the
uh
I don't I got it on here, but I don't
know if my license
But anyway, um so it's not going to show
up, I don't think. Um no, we don't do a
trial anymore.
Uh we used to do trials, but uh it was
just difficult to manage. You know,
people would try to work their way
around it.
So anyway, guys, um
I'm going to end it there for now.
You know, I don't want to keep you guys
on all day. But again, you know, if
you're interested in this indicator,
it's it's a neat little indicator.
Uh it's called just go to order flows
Sorry, not even order flows. It's go to
www.deltascalper.com.
And this is the page. Delta's Just type
in deltascalper.com. This will come up.
You know, you can see it on the charts
here.
Um There there's videos on here. Uh this
is an earlier presentation that I did
um a while back.
It's an hour and a half. I mean, today
we've gone about an hour and a half as
well.
And you know, some more charts give you
an idea. You know, the settings I
explained the trade entry signal DAX.
And uh this is uh wheat again. Um that's
mini Dow.
Gold.
And also, it's it's said it's pretty
simple
um to use. There's there's not a whole
heck of a lot of different settings that
you have to
um deal with, right? You don't have to
worry about oh, you know, what's the
slope of this average? You know, what's
this crossover? You know, what am I
going to do with this moving average?
You know, there's none of that stuff,
right? You're basing your trading
decisions off of what's happening right
now in the market. So,
thanks for attending. As I said,
go to deltascalper.com.
Um
I'm going to go Well, I'm going to look
for your email again. If I can't find
it, I'll send you an email that you
could reply. I'll send it from my
personal email.
Um
Bob,
I hope I answered your question. Uh
Jared, I'm going to take a look at your
email about the power bars.
Um
Let me just make a note here. Jared,
power bars.
Uh will
play.
And Bob, if I didn't answer your
question, you should shoot me another
email at my at my Yahoo email. Um
It's fine. Um
cuz I did I did see yours and I I
figured I'd be covering it right in this
presentation anyway. So, have a great uh
day everybody. Thanks for taking the
time out of your Friday. And uh enjoy
Halloween.
And I'll talk to you guys later. Thanks.
Bye-bye.